[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning i'm not only barrack chair
2022 i'm also director at the dodge
telecoms regulatory
organization and we are part of the acm
the authority for consumers and markets
three weeks ago i spoke to our
spokesperson let's call him harry and
harry is the one who tries to think of
the clever alliance you put on linkedin
the ones that you try to tell everything
and sometimes turn out to be quite
meaningless
and harry said to me how come i always
say that we support and we enable and we
promote
when are we when can i finally say that
you are doing something
and i said harry welcome to the
regulator
let me say first i'm very grateful and
honored to be in a room with so many
people who are actually doing the
rollout uh harry couldn't make it today
but i'm sure he's jealous because he
would have loved talking to you so thank
you very much for actually making the
rollout work
second i thought it would be good to
make a bit more concrete in what we do
in barrick
and third is i will conclude on the
happy note that i think
that together we are helping to attain
very ambitious targets that eric already
talked about and that roberto viola also
alert to
so what are we doing in beric
as stated before we are the
organization of the european regulators
and we have a one european framework
which aims to create one european single
digital market
so it's very important to have a
consistent
implementation of that same regulatory
framework but at the same time
of course europe consists of different
economies different markets
different topologies different histories
it is
you talk about rollout in rural sector i
mean the rural sector in the netherlands
is
of course very impressive
but it's hard to to actually compare
that to rolling out in the forest of
sweden rolling out on the islands of
greece or rolling out
on the plains of spain
so we have to make sure that we
implement in an effective and efficient
manner a consistent framework that works
in the diversity of the markets that we
have at
hand and that is what we try to do at
beric
and we do that through first of all
monitoring what is out there
what does our rollout look like
how can we help to pinpoint the wide
spots that we have in the various
markets
to make sure that if governments decide
to provide state aid
they actually target the white areas
and they do not crowd out the private
investment
we don't only monitor we also collect
the practices that we see in the markets
to learn and to formulate best practices
to make sure that we stay
within the boundaries of the regulatory
framework
we stay at um and we all have state of
the art
regulatory implementation
and good practices
and we translate those into guidelines
to make sure that we are transparent
to the markets on the way that we
implement our regulatory work
so we monitor we learn we exchange best
practices we formulate guidelines
to make to enhance our consistency and
we also
provide advice on the different
legislative proposals that are
fabricated or thought of in brussels to
make sure that with all the new
regulation they are all consistent with
one another
and trying to reach that same goal
the very ambitious targets of the
digital and green transition
that the chair of the fda council
already alert to
so what does that mean for fiber rollout
first of all as roberto already told you
the european electronic communication
code which is now being implemented
throughout the various nation states
has some very interesting
innovations that we're now putting into
practice as they are being transposed
international legislation
first of all the code tasks us more
clearly than ever before
to not only make sure
that the
the markets are working and that
competition is at a sufficient level it
also tasks us with promoting investments
and the first way to do that is of
course is to make sure that there is an
adequate level of competition because
competition drives investment
the second way is to make sure that we
have a stable regulatory environment
fiber is of course a game for the long
haul
it's not about quick profits
it's about infrastructure that is going
to last us for quite some time so it's
very important to have a stable
regulatory environment to give you the
kind of certainty that you need
and the third very specific example is
that we are we have started a deep
dialogue within barack
on how we make sure that we guide the
transition from copper to fiber in an
orderly
manner
so last year we made an inventory of
what we are all doing and more than half
of the nras in europe
already have policies in place
that exactly address that issue how to
make sure that the copper legacy is
faced off in a very in an orderly and
consistent manner
to make sure that the business case for
fiber is of course going to be a viable
one
the other one is on sharing
and we have always been very favorable
of sharing passive infrastructure be it
ducts be it poles
but as roberto already said we have also
new instruments in the code
so we can offer much more
regulatory recognition
as it were
to proposals to co-invest
and i think italy has already had the
premiere and we're all looking very much
to that example to see how that works
out
but of course france has already had
some experience
that if you have a co-investment plan
and you share your infrastructure you
will be treated that will be taken into
account
when you talk to a regulator about the
regime that is applicable to that
certain network
so sharing given the enormous capacity
that fiverr promises sharing is much
more something that we are very open to
and are really
looking forward to receiving more
proposals as roberto also stated
and then finally regulation
the rollout itself
is of course
not the aim
for us at barack game is connectivity
for
connecting businesses connecting
consumers connecting citizens connecting
people
connecting organizations
so we regulate there where we still see
that we need
to promote the better workings of the
market where that is in order
but what we do see
and i think that is really an important
trend
is that we deregulate more and more in
europe that was of course always the
goal when we started out 20 years ago
start deregulating as soon as possible
we used to regulate actually 18
different markets in telecoms
at present there's only two designated
by the european commission
from 18 to 2. that doesn't make life any
easier by the way because we have also
been tasked with them making sure it is
much more fit for purpose
and that we take into account the real
situation that we have in every single
region
because the rollout of fiber
has shown us very different players
different than what we're used to in
telecom
we have utility companies
that roll out
we have wholesale only companies we have
companies working together rolling out
and they will start in certain parts of
the country they might start in cities
or they might be
specializing in regional
rollout
so that means that more and more nras
look not at their national market but
start looking really at the region
a country like
denmark
i don't think denmark is when you think
of a large country you don't think of
denmark
it's not the first country that comes to
mind
it designated 21 different geographical
markets
and deregulated most of them
on the fiber part
recently
so we are paying closer attention to
what is happening out there
and making more fit for purpose
regulation
as we go about it
so where does that bring us
at berg we've said that the real aim we
have is making sure that we promote
meaningful end-to-end connectivity
serving societal needs
as i said our first strategic objective
is promoting full connectivity
we are technology neutral
but for us full connectivity is in line
with the european digital targets
in very high capacity networks
means a gigabit and serving societal
needs means we take sustainability
as a very important parameter
we support sustainable and open digital
markets we welcome new players we always
look out
whether there's enough competition
enough chances for different companies
to get to run a good business and to
serve customers
and we empower end users
and i think that the way that we have
been
enabling supporting
promoting
helping
has
has brought us in europe with
very ambitious targets and rightfully so
but
we have also come a long way
and i had a look at the numbers for 2020
comparing the european uh homes passed
with uh with the american homes passed
and they're both around 40
and as we already started
in the opening speak to the president of
the council
saying that we already passed a 50 point
and as a regulator i'm not only
interested in homes past i'm interested
in homes connected
homes connected
to high speeds to make sure that
everybody can profit and everybody
can contribute
to europe's digital future
and in that respect thank you so much
for the digital rollout and as i told
harry we're very happy to help
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you